THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE"
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
THE BETTER DONALD TRUMP DOES AA
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS, THE
MORE DEMOCRATS SHAME HIM.
WHEN YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICANS
WERE INVITED TO THE WHITE HOUSE
BY THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE DERIDED BY THE LEFT.
>> THEY USED YOUNG BLACKS AS
PROPS WHICH IS AN INSULT TO
THEM.
>> Laura: INSULT TO THEM?
REALLY.
AREN'T THOSE RACIST SENTIMENTS?
ISN'T IT WRONG TO LUMP PEOPLE
INTO POLITICAL CAMPS OR BELIEVE
ONLY AUTHENTIC AFRICAN-AMERICANS
DESPISE DONALD TRUMP.
WHY SHOULD A REVEREND BE
SPEAKING OF THESE TERMS AT ALL?
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
PROSPECTS.
NOW THE LEFT ARE ENGAGED IN A
COORDINATED EFFORT TO BRAND
DONALD TRUMP AS A RACIST.
>> WE HAVE A WHITE NATIONALIST
PRESIDENT.
>> PEOPLE KNOW WHEN YOU SAY
NATIONALISM, PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THAT IS A DOGMA FOR.
THAT'S A WINK AND NOD TO WHITE
NATIONALIST.
>> THIS MAN DOUBLED DOWN AFTER
11 BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE WERE SHOT
AND KILLED WHILE WORSHIPPING.
FOR WHAT?
SOME IDEAL OF RIGHTNESS THAT
DONALD TRUMP SPEWS OUT OF HIS
MOUTH EVERY DAY.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT DONALD
TRUMP THINKS ABOUT EVERY DAY.
YOU ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
AND THIS TIRESOME CLAIM.
>> TRUMP KNOWS THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN ENERGIZE THEIR BASES IS
THROUGH FEAR.
>> Sean: I THOUGHT SHE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE FUNNY.
FEAR MONGERING.
WHAT WAS OPRAH WINFREY DOING IN
ATLANTA IF NOT FEAR MONGERING?
>> I AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE MEN AND THE WOMEN WHO WERE
LYNCHED, WHO WERE HUMILIATED,
AND WHO WERE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST AND WHO WERE SUPPRESSED
AND REPRESSED AND OPPRESSED.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I REFUSE TO LET THEIR
SACRIFICES BE IN VAIN.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE TO HAND IT TO
OPRAH.
SHE IS A GREAT SPEAKER.
I LIKED HERBERT WHEN SHE WAS
GIVING WAY TOYOTAS.
TO TIE THE CANDIDACY OF KEMP TO
RACISM AND LYNCHING?
COME ON.
THAT'S BASELESS.
IT'S TOTALLY CRUEL AND YOU ARE
MUCH BETTER THAN THAT AND MUCH
BIGGER THAN THAT.
I SAY THIS TO OPRAH, HOW IS THIS
LIVING OUR BEST LIFE NOW?
THIS DESENSITIZES US TO THE REAL
RACISTS WHO SHOULD BE CONDEMNED
AND PROSECUTED WHEN THEY COMMENT
HEINOUS CRIMES AND USE VIOLENCE
TO HURT AND MAIM PEOPLE OF A
DIFFERENT RACE.
WHAT DID KEMP EVER DO ASIDE FROM
RUNNING AGAINST A BLACK
OPPONENT?
NOTHING.
FOR A TASTE OF TRUE RACIAL
OBSESSION, HEAR WHAT A FEW
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS SAID THIS
WEEK THAT DIDN'T GET THAT MUCH
ATTENTION.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF CORY
BOOKER?
>> I ADORE HIM.
>> SAYING KICK THEM IN THE
CHINS?
>> THAT WAS HOLDER.
>> SORRY.
>> I KNOW THEY ALL LOOK ALIKE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> OUR STATE DIRECTOR IS
INDIAN-AMERICAN BUT HE DOES AN
AMAZING JOB.
OUR DIRECTOR OF CONSTITUENT
SERVICES WITH AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
BUT SHE DOES A MORE INCREDIBLE
JOB THAN YOU COULD EVER MAG.
>> Laura: [LAUGHING].
I STILL CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
COMMENT.
IN FLORIDA A STAFFER OF GILLUM
SAID THIS ABOUT HIS PROMISES AND
ABOUT THE STATE ITSELF.
>> FAIRY TALES IN THE MODERN-DAY
BEGIN WITH ONCE I AM ELECTED.
>> THIS IS A [BLEEP] STATE.
>> Laura: IMAGINE IF A
CONSERVATIVE STAFFER FOR RON
DESANTIS SAID SOMETHING SIMILAR.
IT WOULD BE WALL-TO-WALL NEWS
DAY AND NIGHT.
HE AND THE CANDIDATE WOULD BE
LABELED AS RACIST.
A PATHETIC DOUBLE STANDARD IS
WHAT WE SHOWED YOU.
YOU KNOW THEY WON'T COVER THAT.
THAT'S JUST SOME FRINGE GUY
MAKING A VIDEO.
DEMOCRATS LIKE GILLUM ARE
FEATURED IN PIECES ACROSS ALL
MEDIA.
MOST OF THESE PIECES FOCUS ON
THEIR RACE AS THE BIGGEST
SELLING POINT.
I ASSUME THEY ARE ABOUT MORE
THAN THAT.
THEY HAVE VIEWS AND IDEAS.
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT RACE AND RACE
ALONE.
BLACK REPUBLICANS LIKE JOHN
JAMES RUNNING FOR SENATE OR OMAR
A MUSLIM REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS ARE HARDLY COVERED AT
ALL.
RACE DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN.
NOT HISTORIC AT ALL.
THE REASON FOR THIS LEFTIST RACE
BAITING TRUMP'S POLICIES ARE
WORKING FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AND THE RESULTS ARE COMING IN.
DEMOCRATS SENSE IT.
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR GRIP ON
THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT IS TOWN AND
THE POLLS ARE MOVING.OWN AND
THE POLLS ARE MOVING.
CHECK OUT THIS POLL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S APPROVAL
RATING IS ALMOST TRIPLE.
LOOK AT THIS:
THIS MAY BE THE MOST REVEALING
NUMBER OF ALL.
ON THE ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION.
15% OF BLACK AMERICANS LIKE
TRUMP'S APPROACH LAST YEAR.
NOT GREAT.
THIS YEAR ALMOST DOUBLED.
29% APPROVE OF TRUMP'S
IMMIGRATION STANCE.
YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE EVERYTHING HE
TWEETS BUT DONALD TRUMP IS
STANDING UP FOR ALL AMERICANS.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT YOUR SKIN
COLOR OR WHAT RELIGION YOU
PRACTICE.
HE IS ABOUT AMERICA.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
AND BACK TO OBAMA, BECAUSE HE IS
CAMPAIGNING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ASIDE FROM HIS INCREDIBLE
EXAMPLE OF BEING A GREAT FATHER
AND HIMSELF A HISTORIC FIGURE.
YOU HAVE TO ASK THIS QUESTION:
WHAT DID OBAMA ACTUALLY DO FOR
BLACK AMERICA?
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WAGES DURING
HIS 8 YEARS WERE FLAT.
OBAMACARE WAS A COMPLETE AND
TOTAL DISASTER.
HE DID LITTLE TO PROTECT THE
BLACK COMMUNITY FROM THE
COMPETITION OF CHEAP, ILLEGAL
LABOR.
HARDLY TALKED ABOUT IT.
DO NOT LET THE RACE HUSKSTERS
CONVINCE YOU TO EMBRACE THE
FAILURE OF THE PAST.
FOR DEMOCRATS THIS IS NOT ABOUT
PROTECTING MINORITIES, IT'S
ABOUT REGAINING RAW POLITICAL
POWER EVEN IF IT MEANS TURNING